it's George Monbiot he's a guardian
journalist and author his best-selling
books include captive state the
corporate takeover of Britain the age of
consent a manifesto for a new world
order and most recently out of the
wreckage and new politics for an age of
crisis George over to you
thanks very much for each of them now I
realized that in calling for you to vote
for this motion I'm making quite a tough
ask here to come for the end of
capitalism in the 21st century is like
saying god is dead in the 19th and
perhaps it's a particularly tough ask
for people who've paid 30 quid to get in
but I know you're a broad-minded and
intellectually curious Bunch
otherwise you wouldn't be here so I'm
gonna ask you hard as I know it is to
the greatest extent possible to put
aside all prior beliefs and judge the
arguments this evening on their merits
which of course will inevitably mean
that far harder and I win this vote
mm-hmm so what is capitalism it might be
quite a useful starting point to agree
on our Terms well it's an economic
system which is whose means of prayer
the means of production are privately
owned for the purpose of generating
profits and accumulating wealth it can
be distinguished from other forms of
profit seeking by the general
commodification of land labour and money
as such its origins date back to about
the mid 16th century in England and as a
mature system it's about 200 years old I
hope we can all agree broadly on that as
a definition I hope we can also all
agree on what climate collapses climate
collapse is what happened somewhere
north of 1.5 degrees of global heating
above pre-industrial levels this is why
the Paris agreement calls on the
governments which have signed it
including our own to keep temperature
levels well below two degrees and to
seek to keep them at 1.5 degrees at two
degrees we see the loss of almost all
the world's coral reefs we see ice-free
sea at the Arctic becoming a regular
event with devastating consequences as
runaway feedbacks kick in the dark water
absorbing more heat the permafrost
releasing its carbon we've seen
recent papers suggesting what they call
multiple bread basket failures the
world's crucial food production regions
being taken out at the same time by
simultaneous heat waves we see major
cities threatened by inundation I hope
too we can all agree that is climate
collapse now I'm going to argue that
capitalism has three essential and
intrinsic features without which it
would not be capitalism that drive us
inexorably towards climate collapse and
the first of these is growth growth is
essential to capitalism without growth
capitalism is deemed to fail the rising
growth in consumption is the aggregate
impact of profit seeking activities in
other words it's the inevitable result
of capitalism as successfully practiced
and this leads to a slight problem that
perpetual growth which is what
capitalism seeks on a finite planet
leads inexorably to environmental
disaster now those who seek to justify
the system will say well hang on a
moment that growth can be decoupled from
its environmental impacts you can have
rising growth and falling environmental
impacts now we know that where material
resource consumption the resumption of
stuff is concerned that has never been
demonstrated however it does appear to
be the case in some nations where
greenhouse gas emissions are concerned
there's a famous study by the World
Resources Institute which said that
across developed nations and richest
nations in the world thirty-five richest
nations we saw between 2000 and 2014 a
general reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions even as economic growth rose
in those places and for instance in the
UK we saw a 24% reduction
across that period even while there was
a 27% increase in consumption in
economic growth but it's not quite as it
seems because what that study was
looking at is what's called territorial
emissions the greenhouse gases you
produce within your own nation when
carbon brief reanalyzed the figures it
looked at consumption emissions the
greenhouse gases for which you're
responsible in the goods that your
nation imports embodied in those Goods
and that reduced the 24 percent to 9
percent across the 15 years about 0.6
percent a year reductions in greenhouse
gases when you then take an account take
account of flying and shipping which are
not included in those figures it comes
out more or less at zero now a recent
study by the UN Environment Program says
that test and a good chance of
preventing more than 1.5 degrees of
global heating we need to cut greenhouse
gas emissions by 7.6 percent per year
for that for the next 10 years not zero
or not as it may now be minus two minus
seven point six percent well hang on a
minute during this entire period of the
study 2002-2014 the British government
and the British people in general are
making massive efforts to cut greenhouse
gas emissions we passed the climate
change act the government spent billions
on subsidizing renewables we got out of
coal largely and into gas a really
important transition moment you know not
important enough but it should have made
a huge difference we insulated our homes
we changed our lightbulbs so how come we
reflect lining well the answer is that
those efforts were counteracted by
economic growth that trying to cut your
impacts while your economy is growing
while resource consumption is growing
means running down the rising escalator
it makes it difficult if not impossible
and the same applause
to the next to intrinsic features of
capitalism the second one is this
feature which has been there since John
Locke's Second Treatise of government
and absolutely central feature of
capitalism which is the assumption that
the money in your bank account equates
to your right to own natural wealth you
can own as much land as much gold as
much you can eat as much meat or fish as
you want you can have and you can create
as much burn as much carbon as you like
as long as you've got the money for that
and because of that capitalism is a
really lousy way of solving our problems
because it means that those were the
money take the lion's share depriving
other people and however hard we pursue
growth we cannot solve them so one study
for instance shows that to reduce
poverty by one dollar you need to
generate 111 dollars of economic growth
on the current trajectory to ensure that
everybody through growth gets five
dollars a day we would it would take 200
years we would need to raise the size of
the global economy 170 times but even at
current levels of economic growth we are
bursting through environmental limits
170 times is not the end of poverty it's
the end of life on earth and then
there's the third feature which is a
promise
central to capitalism that everyone can
aspire to private luxury we can all
become rich now even if it weren't for
that distributional problem which I
mention there's another issue there are
simply not enough environmental space
for everybody to aspire to private
luxury the only reason that some people
can do it is that other people don't
otherwise we end up just cooking
ourselves in very short order the
richest 1% in the world use a hundred
and seventy five times as much carbon as
the poorest 10% is everyone supposed to
use the same amount
these three features of capitalism turn
it into a gun pointed at the living
world we cannot sustain a habitable
climate and sustain capitalism instead
we need a system based on a different
principle of private sufficiency and
public luxury there's enough for
everyone as long as we share it there is
not enough as long as we seek to
accumulate it and to keep raising our
aggregate and individual consumption you
cannot make those changes while still
calling it capitalism there's an old and
vaguely attributed saying which is that
it's easier to imagine the end of the
world than it is to imagine the end of
capitalism my friends I want you to
mobilize your imaginations tonight the
question that faces us is do we stop
capitalism to allow life to continue or
stop life to allow capitalism to
continue thank you
[Applause]
you